murder ball was uh
these this uh sport for
like para athletes like uh paraplegics
yeah like um paralyzed guys and this one
guy was hanging out with partying
and and uh he's like oh dude can you
help me with my catheter
right he's all hammered he's got to pee
and i'm like all right you know i'm a
bro
and i i grabbed his wiener i put the
catheter
really yeah that's nice of you yeah and
i was like hey dude no big deal man
i'm cool like that i'm very secure with
myself so
how do you get a catheter in there i
would it like you kind of have to
hold it and like i mean spit on it shut
up you got to get it you gotta drink it
yeah get it hard
i can't remember it i i it was a long
long long time ago
damn but these guys are i'm a little i'm
a little concerned about that because
they do have use of their arms they're
playing
why would he need help he's
a quadriplegic that's a good question
i don't know that's [ __ ] hilarious
dude
yeah dude